nearly eight thousand of our viewers
regularly participate in political
discussion and debate and conversation
on our subreddit I regularly visit the
subreddit I know Pat regularly visits
the subreddit and I invite you to visit
at david pakman.com slash reddit our e d
di t very very important issue was
brought up this morning on the subreddit
and it relates to the upcoming midterm
elections and it is about voter D
registration this is just one story
where a user said went to verify my
voter registration today no record of me
being registered despite having voted in
the previous elections this is not a
unique problem and I am NOT saying this
to be conspiratorial I am not saying
this for any reason other than a lot of
people have been emailing me saying this
is not going to be my first time voting
I have not moved I've had no change of
address I've had no otherwise change of
status I've not been divorced and
changed my name
there is no reason whatsoever for me to
no longer show up as a registered voter
and I am not showing up as a registered
voter so I you know we often end up
realizing that this is going on very
shortly before an election so what there
what you need to do right now is number
one confirm that you are registered at
this point I believe that the deadlines
have passed for registration in many
states although not in all I think you
can still register up through October of
course other than states that have
same-day registration look into the
rules in your state but if you're
someone who has voted before and you
assume that you were registered my
recommendation is make sure that you're
actually registered and the the number
of people who are who have been telling
me I am not showing up as registered is
very very concerning to me and if you
are not registered and the deadline has
passed you do need to contact the
Secretary of State or voting officials
even the Federal Election Committee and
explain here's my record of having voted
before or having been previously
registered or whatever there is no
reason I should not be registered here I
need to be able to vote in November very
very important and even though it's
horrible I'm glad that it was posted
about to the subreddit also from the
david pakman show subreddit a story
about politican i mentioned earlier this
week that i have been invited to
participate in politican but that a lot
of people and the audience have been
saying David that is the lowest form of
political debate please don't
participate and I asked for feedback the
overwhelming response including from
this subreddit user is that I need to go
to politican and that no matter what the
format is no matter how toxic the entire
milieu of right-wingers who are going to
be there debating is that my presence
would only help if I go and I do my
thing which is the same thing I do when
I go on Fox News or on any adversarial
media so that seems to be the consensus
as of now I still have no idea by the
way what it is they want me doing there
I know Kyle kolinsky has already been
told he's debating and Coulter I know
some of the other people that are going
have been told what they're doing I
still haven't been told and I'm emailing
them every couple days and I don't know
what's going on so for people saying am
i doing a debate one-on-one am i
participating in a panel am I going to
be moderating a debate I have absolutely
no idea and I've told them I typically
before any kind of speaking engagement
or public thing I'll have like six or
eight weeks to prepare and at this point
we are only five weeks away based on the
based on October 20th and 21st or 22nd
that those days those dates are so I'm
not keeping you in the dark I just don't
know what I'm going to be doing join the
discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit david pakman.com slash re d di
t